the message tonight in california
rethink
before heading to nevada this is our
state rival tops in the country for
increasing covid rates
our neighbors also reinstating indoor
mass wearing policy starting on saturday
one of several steps california is
taking to curb covid19
infection sasha loftus spoke with a
local expert tonight
to see what this means for us here at
home
denise and brian many of the people we
spoke with out here on the strip today
say they're not too worried about this
most recent kovid 19 spike
on the other hand many were putting
their masks back on
the local expert i spoke with says it is
concerning to see
he also said we can all do our part to
help
after months of downward trends kovid 19
is
once again on the rise in nevada
groups are gathering mass are few and
far between
and vaccination numbers aren't quite
where they should be
there are more people not wearing masks
than our employee mask and
you know that a lot of these people are
still not vaccinated yet
now as our case positivity rate surges
above 10 percent
los angeles county is asking people to
reconsider
travel to our state you've got to be
cautious nowadays and be safe
i think we live our lives within reason
but normally
reaction among visitors is mixed but
dena the unlv school of medicine
dr mark j khan says we shouldn't ignore
these changes
people are starting to let down their
guard and get together
and the group that's most concerning are
the unvaccinated
he tells me nearly everyone hospitalized
with covid 19 here in nevada is not
vaccinated
we're starting to see a switch and who
gets admitted to the hospital now it's
younger people
again who have not been vaccinated but
he says the solution
is simple immunization will stop the
spread
why would you not want to be vaccinated
you know why would you not want to be
safe protect yourself protect
others and allow us all to keep enjoying
the city we know and love
safely please get vaccinated also wear
your mask
now as of now there are no plans to
reinstate mass mandates here in nevada
i also asked dr khan if there was a
possibility our numbers could get
as bad as they were before the
vaccination roll out
here in nevada he says that is very
unlikely because a decent amount of
people
are immunized reporting live in las
vegas tonight sasha loftis
8 news now